you don't have to do it the way
everybody else has done it you can do it
your way you can break the rules you
just can't get in the way of somebody
else getting what they want that's rule
number one
I was watching the Olympics and I was
amazed at how bad the questions were
that the reporters would ask all the
athletes were you nervous and to a tee
all the athletes went no and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous it's their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what it what happens when you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that is I'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say as nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you used to feet speak in front of a
large audience and somebody'd say how do
you feel you say a little nervous now
when somebody says how do you feel I'm
like really excited actually and it it
came from just sort of telling myself no
no this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective it makes you want to rush for
is rather than pull back and yet it's
the same experience you just watch two
amazing clips from Simon sonic take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]